Hey youtubers it's Charlie, and my friends
at Geek and Sundry are making this cool new
Gae Bolg from Final Fantasy Realm Reborn in
real life, so I wanted to do another bonus
video talking about the Lore of the Game and
some of the other legendary weapons and put
it into perspective with the rest of the Final
Fantasy Series.
So in the episode they talk a little about
why the Gae Bolg is so much cooler than 99
Percent of all the other weapons. It's Legendary,
anyone who's played WoW or really any MMO
for that matter knows that Legendary Items
appear like once or twice on a server with
a few exceptions. There are craftable Legendaries,
just weapons that start out being cool and
allow you to reforge with other rare boss
drops till eventually you have your Legendary.
I think in WoW my guild had to grind Firelands
on Heroic for a month just to get our Boomkin
his Dragonwrath staff. The fun kind of wore
off after the first few weeks, but look how
shiny!
In Realm Reborn the Gae Bolg is one of 9 Relic
Weapons that you obtain after an epic boss
grind and a bunch of other mission completions.
The start quest is actually titled "A Relic
Reborn". The weapons are all specific to each
Job. They are, in no particular order:
The Artemis Bow for the Bard
The Bravura for the Warrior
The Curtana and Holy Shield for the Paladin
The Gae Bolg for the Dragoon
The Omnilex for the Scholar
The Sphairai for the Monk
The Stardust Rod for the Mage
The Veil of Wiyu for the Summoner
and The Thyrus for the White Mage
You could write a book for the steps needed
to obtain all these relic weapons, so generally
once you get one, you have one of the best
weapons in the game. Usually it takes a new
expansion before everything gets nerfed and
there's a new precious to grind for.
In their new video Nika actually talked to
one of the GMs from Square Enix about Dragoons
specifically just because they forged a Gae
Bolg in real life. Dragoons are historically
famous for fighting Dragons, but they've been
featured in all of the Final Fantasy Games
since Final Fantasy 2. Sometimes it's just
as reference and not as a playable character.
Final Fantasy 4 on the Super Nintendo was
my introduction to Dragoons and the Series
in General. In that game Kain was the only
Dragoon and he was more of a foil for you
as the protagonist. In each iteration of the
game the Gae Bolg is the signature weapon.
It looks like a pike just because they needed
to be able to fight dragons without having
to get in close like you would with a traditional
sword. So I applaud the creators of all the
different games for keeping character traits
consistent across 30 plus years of a game
franchise. That's better continuity than the
X-Men Movie Franchise.
Realm Reborn incorporates a lot of the lore
of the Dragoons built up since the beginning
of the franchise. So if you've played a lot
of different versions of the game your character
traits and skills will look really familiar.
It also pays homage to a lot of Dragoon characters
you encounter having the surname Highwind
just because across the franchise they've
kept it a thing that all of the dragoons flow
from Kain Highwind and his family. They built
a lot of that lore into the old Final Fantasy
2 game back in the 80s. So JRPGs aren't just
cool now, they've always been that cool.
That's why you see a lot of story teams created
when big western games like Halo or other
Western RPGs are in development. People in
America learned from Japanese game makers
how important story are lore was and started
to integrate it into new games. That's why
the best games always have the best stories.
If you look at the Gae Bolg Nika built yes
she's not a giant, but the scale is 1 to 1.
So if you were using a polearm on Game of
Thrones or any other medieval series. It would
be the same size. They got a person to test
it out, he's part of the Armored Combat League.
They're like a sports league that LARPS and
uses real life armor and weapons to do tourney
sports. So all the stuff you see them using
you would have also seen on the battlefield
in the middle ages.
They got to stab a lot of stuff and even tried
to replicate the Dragoon jump attack. You
have to remember real life physics kind of
sucks, just because you're carrying like an
extra hundred pounds of weight. So it would
be like strapping cinder blocks to your feet
and trying to slam dunk a basketball. If you
can do that, you're probably making millions
of dollars in the NBA right now.
I'd say my other favorite class to play in
Final Fantasy games is Black Mage, yes they're
super cool to watch, but from a practical
standpoint if you can learn to deal with being
a squishy cloth wearer, you get way more powerful
attacks. So you're one of the best DPS classes.
Unless you're fighting someone with high magic
resist. Then yes, you're just squishy. Usually
it's a lot easier to learn melee classes first
just because it's a lot of hack and slash.
But I think Mages are way more useful later
in the game.
The issue you run into with MMOs in general
is class tuning, so as you start maxing out
your gear, all classes start to become equally
useful in raid.
So Realm Reborn is basically Final Fantasy
14 and even though they released Lightning
Returns recently, Final Fantasy 15 has been
in development since before 2006. They even
showed footage of it at E3 in 2006. The reason
it takes so long to release a new numbered
sequel to the franchise is because they change
everything about the game so much with each
new iteration.
And remember what games looked like in 2006
versus right now. They've had to redesign
everything several times. There isn't any
official release date other than 2015 fingers
crossed. In keeping with recent tradition,
the game jumps to a much more modern looking
time, like the difference between Final Fantasy
8 and Final Fantasy 9, one is super techy
and the other is super steam punky.
The last update we got from Square Enix was
in February, and they said it was really far
into development, that's kind of vague, so
I'm expecting it to drop around November or
December 2015 unless we get to E3 next year
and they have nothing. Games take way longer
to make than movies, so don't be surprised
if it takes even longer to finish.
So in related news, I'll be doing a couple
more bonus weapon lore videos in the next
couple of weeks. Be sure to subscribe to get
everything. Eventually later this summer I'll
just move these types of videos to my Gaming
Channel Charlie Streams. Feel free to send
me suggestions for games to include.
Right now click here to watch Geek and Sundry
make the Final Fantasy Gae Bolg in real life.
It's really cool. And click here for my Elder
Scrolls Lore Video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!